sometimes when we talk about the history
of philosophy in the islamic world
the narrative presented is that it
starts with al-qindi in the 9th century
and ends with the andalusian figure ibn
rust
known in the west as avarois or averroes
as i've discussed in previous videos
this understanding is based on rather
narrow understanding of philosophy and a
selective misreading of later
developments in the region
but we can still say that ibn rush
represents a very important
moment in the history of islamic
philosophy and its development
he was a radical rationalist one who
championed the philosophy of aristotle
to such a degree that he considered some
of his predecessors like ibn cena and
al-farabi
to be irrational neoplatonists his life
and thought is
fascinating from his relationship to
different rulers to his role as a judge
in islamic law
and his very entertaining intellectual
beef with al ghazali
it all adds up to a very interesting
figure that is worth studying
and admiring
[Music]
was a muslim polymath who mastered a
number of different fields
he wrote over a hundred books on such
varied topics as theology physics
metaphysics
linguistics medicine astronomy and law
just to mention a few
he was born in cordoba in modern spain
in the year 1126
and his full name was abul walid
muhammad
as it was known was at the time ruled by
the muslim al-murabi dynasty
a group of berber muslim leaders who had
taken over
after the crumbling of the umayyad
caliphate in the region
the al-muravids and their successor the
al-muhadz who
would take over soon thereafter in 1150
were both pretty strict and puritanical
in their understanding and
implementation of islamic law
and practice but the region still
flourished in terms of intellectual
development and
activity ibn roost came from a family of
renowned scholars and jurists of the
maliki school of law which was the
predominant school in that region at the
time and he would himself follow in
their footsteps as just one aspect of
his varied intellectual life
he seems to have received a wide
education in both the religious sciences
being taught by
some of his family members and their
friends as well as being highly educated
and learned
in the philosophical and scientific
subjects as well
one story tells of how he traveled to
marrakesh as a young man to do some
astronomical calculations now marrakech
at the time was the seed of power for
the al-maha dynasty which would
soon thereafter rule much of north
africa and basically all of andalusia
the situation with the al-muhads is
quite complex
it is true that they were very
puritanical and strict in their
understanding and implementation of the
sharia islamic law as well as on
certain theological questions but at the
same time the founder ibn tumar
and his followers also affirmed that
rationality was an important and
legitimate sort of way to understand
religion in a general sense
so here the al-muhads actually kind of
question
some of our often preconceived notions
about how these things should work
a rational attitude is often associated
with a more
liberal kind of social approach but this
was not the case here
so as a result of this under the
al-mahad some of the fans of
philosophers received patronage from
their rulers and would come to have high
status and positions in the court and in
society
as would also be the case here with ibn
rust it is said that on this trip to
marrakesh
ibn rushd ran into the great philosopher
ibn tufail
writer of the famous novel hai ibn
yakshan
now i've dedicated a whole video to this
philosopher and that novel in particular
which you can find on my channel even to
fail was also at the time the court
physician to the ruling al-mahd calif
abu yakub yusuf the stories differ here
but it is said that it was ibn tufail
who actually introduced
the caliph to ibn rust perhaps
recognizing his great intellectual
capabilities
in one story ibn rushd is brought before
the caliph abiya kobe yusuf and even to
fail
the caliph then asks ibn rushd about the
heavens and the
eternity of the universe which was quite
a controversial
and hot topic at the time so ibn rosh
gave a very kind of safe
cop-out answer to not sort of get in
trouble basically
but following this the caliph then
turned to eben to fail his physician
and they started discussing the matter
in depth which showed ibn rush that the
caliph was not only
interested in philosophical speculation
but actually quite educated and
intelligent himself
and this gave ibn rushdie courage to
jump into the conversation and really
show off what he knew
and the the knowledge that he had and
this seems to have very much
impressed the caliph and even to fail
and this could be seen then as the start
of ibn rush's very privileged career
he would continue to study the different
philosophical and
sciences as well as becoming prominent
in islamic law as well
he became a kadhi a judge and was
eventually appointed the
chief judge in cordoba and this is
important to keep in mind as
many later commentators in europe have
argued that
ibn rush's commitment to islam as a
religion must have been only on a kind
of surface level
and that he didn't really believe in it
so to say but when we study his life we
can see that he was deeply committed to
the religion of islam
its laws and its practices just because
you have a biased view of islam as being
irrational and can't imagine a
rationalist like
ibn rush being a devout muslim doesn't
make it true
once even to fail retired in 1182
ibn rushd also took over his position as
the court physician to the caliph
abyakov yosuf
as well as to his successor abu yusuf
yakub
another very creative name now
throughout his career ibn rush would
write a huge amount of works about all
kinds of different topics
relating to what we refer to as science
today philosophy religion
law and so on he can very much be called
a polymath and was undoubtedly a
genius in many ways in his philosophical
thought he was particularly a strong
follower of
aristotle and wanted to revive what he
thought was
a true aristotelian philosophy he wrote
quote i believe that this man aristotle
was a model in nature and the exemplar
which nature
found for showing final human perfection
very high praise obviously now basically
all
muslim philosophers liked aristotle and
saw themselves as being followers of
aristotle
there are some exceptions like ibn
sabain or surahwardi who would
in in the writings become quite critical
of that approach but
generally all muslim philosophers saw
themselves in some way
as primarily followers of aristotle but
at the same time most of them were also
very highly influenced by platonism and
neoplatonism in particular
in the medieval islamic world there were
rarely a distinction drawn between the
teachings of plato and aristotle
and so there was often a kind of
synthesis between the two for example
one of the main
sources for greek philosophy in the
early islamic world
that was translated into arabic from
greek was a treatise called the theology
of
aristotle which became incredibly
influential and and
used throughout the islamic world now
today we know that the theology of
aristotle
is actually a section from the iniads by
platinus
who is the founder of neoplatonism so
unknowingly many of the islamic
philosophers
confused what they thought was
aristotle's teachings with
what was actually plutonius and so the
later's teachings
of course inevitably enters and became
very important and influential to
the writings and ideas of much of the
islamic philosophers generally
and it does present in the thought of
philosophers like ibn sina
and al-farabi ibn rushd was very much
aware of this
and was critical of it he was
particularly skeptical of ibn cena and
his followers who whose revolutionary
ideas had an enormous impact in the
islamic intellectual world
as he believed that the great persian
philosopher had soiled
the pure rationalism of aristotle with
neoplatonist ideas
instead he wanted to return philosophy
to an earlier state
to a time before ibn cena and to the
earliest philosophers in baghdad
and even further back to aristotle
himself essentially
thus ibn rush wrote a huge amount of
commentaries on the works of aristotle
often divided into three kinds short
commentaries
middle commentaries and long
commentaries
the latter of which was a line-by-line
in-depth commentary on the works of
aristotle on all of his different
books and this huge amount of and
incredibly in-depth
commentary on aristotle earned him the
simple but
very telling name the commentator by
later western thinkers primarily
aristotle himself had been known simply
as the
philosopher in the islamic world and ibn
rush being given the title
the commentator says a lot about his
status
and his relationship to aristotle the
second important thing and aspect of ibn
rush's ideas and thought
is the relationship between philosophy
and
religion ibn rush being a philosopher
and strong rationalist as well as a
devout muslim
spends much of his writing very strongly
arguing not only for the
compatibility between religion and
philosophy but to their essential
interconnectedness
not only did ibundrosh consider
philosophy to be
permitted that is halal in arabic he
even consider it based on
quranic verses to be obligatory for
everyone who had the ability to study it
he believed that the quran asks its
readers to investigate and ask
questions about creation these questions
are discussed throughout his corpus of
works but primarily in two very famous
texts one of them is a direct response
to the great theologian and sufi
al-ghazali
if you remember in my video about
anahazali he wrote a very influential
work called tahafoot al-falasifah
or the incoherence of the philosophers
in which he strongly attacks the
philosophers and some other ideas in
particular ibn sina
and al-farabi he considers a lot of
their philosophy to be completely
incompatible
with islamic orthodoxy now ibn rust who
writes a few decades
later wouldn't have any of this so he
wrote a direct response to al-ghazali's
incoherence of the philosophers
called the tahafoot attahafot the
incoherence of the incoherence
in which he attacks al ghazali's claims
and defends
philosophy i've always loved this back
and forth between these two it's like a
medieval rap feud or something it's just
i just love it but nonetheless in this
important work he very much
strongly and seriously defends
philosophy and attacks al-ghazali on a
number of points
and one of them by actually agreeing
with him as the bulk of al-ghazali's
critique is aimed at the philosopher ibn
cena
ibn could do nothing but agree he also
was critical of
ibn cena but instead he asks al ghazali
to not
judge or or deem all philosophy to be
wrong
just because one person had the wrong
ideas
just like you wouldn't say that all of
fick or jurisprudence
is misguided just because one single
jurist had some
iffy ideas another way that he
criticizes al-ghazali is an aspect that
is central
to his general ideas and that is the
dividing arguments and statements into
demonstrative statements and dialectical
or rhetorical statements
to him that is the only way to know
truth definitively is through
demonstrative proof
a demonstrative statement could be a
syllogism based on a premise that is
immediately
true so for example if a equals b and
b also equals c then that must
necessarily mean that a
equals c much of modern science is based
on this kind of reasoning
that is truth derived from demonstrated
evidence or
reasoning a simply rhetorical statement
however can potentially be true
but is not true per se it is not
immediately true
in itself so if i say the earth revolves
around the sun
that isn't truth in itself the statement
itself doesn't prove that what i'm
saying is true
even if it is true in this case anyway
to put it simply ibn rush believed that
it was the philosopher's job
to only work with demonstrated proofs
and
truths and not simply rhetorical ones
which he criticized the kalam scholars
and al-ghazali as doing and he applies
these general ideas into his
ideas about the relationship between
religion and philosophy generally too
much like other philosophers that we
have described in other videos like al
kindly and al-farabi
ibn rush believes that the truth that we
can derive
from reasoning or through scientific
demonstration
is essentially the same truth that is
expressed in religion
he has sometimes been attributed with
the idea of a double truth
that is that there is one truth for
religion and another
truth for philosophy and science but
this is not actually accurate
he believed that the truth that can be
reached through reason
and demonstration is essentially the
same exact
truth that is expressed in revelation in
the quran
and again like the other philosophers he
argues that these two only use different
languages to express the same thing the
philosophical language is meant for
the philosophers who can grasp these
abstract concepts
whereas the language of revelation and
the quran
is a rhetorical one of symbols and
metaphors that
expresses the same truths but to the
wider masses
quote the natures of men are on
different levels with respect to ascent
one of them comes to ascend through
demonstration another comes to ascent
through dialectical arguments
just as firmly as the demonstrative man
through demonstration
and perhaps an even clearer example from
his own writings quote
the religions are according to the
philosopher's obligatory
since they lead towards wisdom in a way
universal to
all human beings for philosophy only
leads a certain number
of intelligent people to the knowledge
of happiness and they therefore have to
learn wisdom
whereas religions seek the instruction
of the masses
generally now this isn't all that
original as many other philosophers have
expressed basically identical ideas
but ibn rust is especially radical in
his rationalism
and in fact to him rational and
demonstrated proofs
always take precedence over religious
expression
quote we affirm definitely that whenever
the conclusion of a demonstration
is in conflict with the apparent meaning
of scripture
or islamic law that apparent meaning
admits of allegorical interpretation
according to the rules for such
interpretation in arabic
this proposition is questioned by no
muslim and doubted by
no believer in other words if we find
anything in say the quran that goes
against what we know about the world
through demonstration
either philosophical or to extend the
idea scientific
those verses have to be understood
allegorically
or metaphorically now this may be seen
as radical by some people
but it fits perfectly well into his
larger philosophical thought
and this also allows him to defend the
philosophers further from attacks by
al-khazali
as we talked about in the video about
al-ghazali he points out three
main points that the philosophers
express that are completely incompatible
with islamic orthodoxy and
by which he calls them unbelievers and
these are
number one the the idea of the eternity
of the world as opposed to
creation at a specific moment and
secondly the idea that god only knows
universals and not particulars
and lastly the rejection of bodily
resurrection
ibn rust's rationalistic approach allows
him to acquit the philosophers of these
charges
in his understanding of scripture there
are three types of texts or verses
one kind that must always be read
literally a second kind which the
philosophers may interpret allegorically
and a third kind in which there is
disagreement he believed that the
questions discussed by ghazali belong to
the third category where there is
disagreement
and on the basis of this he argues that
for example the question of bodily
resurrection
as long as the person in question
doesn't reject the existence of the
resurrection completely
it is not justified to call him a
catholic or unbeliever
so a scholar can interpret the
resurrection allegorically or
metaphorically
but still affirm that there is a certain
reality to the resurrection even if it
is to be understood
allegorically and however it should be
interpreted and thus he is not a
unbeliever since he doesn't neglect its
existence altogether
so ibn rush allows for an openness of
interpretation and speculation as long
as it is within
the bounds of the quranic statements but
ibn rush nonetheless
ends up affirming many of the points
that the previous philosophers had
for example he very strongly argues for
the eternity of the world instead of it
being created ex nihilo
he believes in the creation of the world
by god but that this doesn't take place
within time
in the words of scholar richard c taylor
quote god
is the creator of the universe in so far
as he draws it from potentiality
into the actuality of existence and also
conserves
it such is the case without entailing a
temporal origination of the world and a
starting moment of time
in an interesting twist ibn rush then
attacks those who actually believe in
creation from nothing at a specific
point in time
and accuses them of reading things
metaphorically and allegorically
and not reading the quran literally
quote
in their statements about the world they
do not conform to the apparent meaning
of scripture
but interpret it for it is not stated
in the scripture that god was existing
with absolutely nothing else
a text to this effect is nowhere to be
found he also in some of his writings
seem to deny bodily resurrection just
like many of the other philosophers
seems to have done but in some places he
even seems to deny any form of
afterlife for the human being at all
which would seem rather strange but
i believe this is a point of debate and
i don't feel comfortable enough to make
any definitive statements about it so
take that with a bit of a grain of salt
the second significant work that ibn
rush wrote on the relationship between
religion and philosophy
is the rather short treatise called
facile
while sharia means which literally
translates to something like
determining the nature of the connection
between wisdom or philosophy
and religion or literally religious law
but sometimes referred to as on the
harmony of religions and philosophy
or simply as the decisive treaties in
this treatise he discusses much of what
we have already talked about
arguing for the essential connectedness
and and uh
complementary relationship between
religion and philosophy or science
these are the things that ibn rushd is
primarily remembered for
he served as chief judge of islamic
maliki law in cordoba
and wrote his masterful philosophical
treatises under the patronage of some of
the al-mahd caliphs
there was a period in 1195 when his luck
suddenly
turned he was tried in cordoba and his
teachings were condemned suddenly by the
caliph he was forced to flee the country
go to
north africa and some of his books were
even burned
many people have speculated about the
reason for this very sudden change in
attitude towards ibn rushd
but most scholars argue that the reasons
were most likely political
as they almost always are fortunately
though this condemnation was only
temporary
and only a year or two later ibn rushd
returned to the court in marrakech he
was
sort of forgiven by the caliph and
continued to be
friends with the sitting almahad calif
for the rest of his life
ibn rushd died on december 11 1198
and was buried in his hometown of
cordoba in modern spain
he left behind a huge corpus of writings
and treatises
not all of which have been discussed in
this video we have only discussed a very
short
small amount of his vast corpus he also
very famously talked about the role of
women in society
and wrote a commentary on plato's very
famous the republic
in this commentary on plato he very
famously expresses his
disdain for the role of women in society
complaining about their
being confined to the home and arguing
that women should play a much more
prominent role
in society at the time our society
allows no scope for the development of
women's
talents they seem to be destined
exclusively to childbirth and the care
of children
and this state of civility has destroyed
their capacity for larger matters
it is thus that we see no women endow
with moral virtues
they live their lives like vegetables
devoting themselves to their husbands
from this stems the misery that pervades
our cities
for women outnumber men by more than
double and cannot procure the
necessities of life by their own labors
another quote women in this state are
twice in numbers as men
and they are kept from working except
rarely in an appropriate labor
and this restricted rarity such as suing
or embroidery
is barely sufficient to help them
survive he argues that women
are actually equal in quality to men in
many respects
they are just as capable of performing
tasks and professions
and he argues that women should get out
and participate more in society
by working or engaging themselves in
social life
in fact this would only benefit society
and particularly the economics of the
state
as there are more women than men as he
clearly stated
quote they that is women are equal with
men in quality and differ only in levels
if this means that man is more efficient
than woman in most of his actions
however
it is not impossible that women perform
some activities with higher efficiency
such as practical music this is why it
is said that melodies are complete if
manhattan composed them
and women have performed them he argues
that women are
fully capable of being philosophers and
hold great wisdom
he also even seems to imply that women
are fully capable of
ruling the state in a political sense
but also at the same time
he seems to be kind of skeptical of this
idea based on islamic law
all of this comes from his commentary on
plato's the republic
and many of these ideas are of course
shared and comes from plato in a lot of
ways
but ibn rushd definitely agrees with
these points and
actually adds certain ideas and certain
perspectives to it
and in this respect where interestingly
he very clearly goes against his
hero aristotle who himself was a lot
more
hostile towards women than plato was
this praising of women and his call for
their
sort of larger participation in society
has led some people to call ibn rush a
proto-feminist
as i always say it is problematic to
ascribe
labels like this to people who lived in
a completely different
context but these ideas that even can
certainly be seen as rather modern and
progressive for his time
but to him this was completely in line
with his understanding of islam and its
religious law
based on his position also as a judge
and jurist of malik islamic law
now what is very interesting about ibn
rust is that he is certainly one of the
most
important and influential philosophers
in history
but at the same time basically none of
that influence can be seen or felt in
the islamic world
he was of course greatly respected and
admired during his lifetime
but after he died his writings had no
lasting or
to any large degree any impact on the
islamic philosophical tradition
it is only in the last century or so
that his ideas have been revived
in the islamic world as a kind of
champion of rationality and a sort of
rational approach to islam
instead it is actually in europe that
ibn rushed has been the most influential
and not just a little bit he was one of
the most significant sources for many of
the medieval christian and jewish
writers on philosophy in general
in a way it can be argued that it is
abundant to hands over the philosophical
intellectual tradition which had
flourished in the islamic world in the
preceding centuries
to the european christians and jews the
christian scholastic traditions are a
whole lot to this man thomas aquinas
maimonides albert the great meister
eckhart
they all read eben ruscht it is even
said that whenever any of the great
scholastic theologians
and philosophers would study the
writings of aristotle
they would always do so with a copy of
ibn rush's commentaries next to it
as i mentioned he was given the title
the commentator for this very reason
and thus he can be said to have had a
massive influence
on the world that we live in today but
as i said his ideas remained largely
ignored in his own
region in his own religion of islam and
islamic philosophy
his predecessor ibn cena and other of
his contemporaries like ibn adabi the
sufis
had a much larger impact and influence
in this
region but i think still he can be
considered one of the most important and
significant
islamic philosophers in history so eben
rust or averroes or abarous as he is
known in the west
he's an incredibly important thinker
he's one of the most significant
philosophers in the islamic
world and one who has had a massive
impact
on european scholasticism and thus also
as i said
generally on the intellectual tradition
of the world and of europe generally i
hope this video was interesting and
informative for you
if you want to support this channel and
my work i would highly appreciate if you
wanted to become a patron
i'll leave a link to that in the
description you can also of course leave
a one-time donation to
a paypal and i'll leave the address to
that also
in the description otherwise you can
simply like the video
you can subscribe to the channel if you
aren't already subscribed
or you can leave a comment and we can
continue this discussion
in the comments section so i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you